[Music]
in school we'd news
what submitted by Joe's toes hello a
school board unanimously voted to allow
medical marijuana use on school grounds
wait is this College oh yeah you know
they used to have cigarette okay at high
schools there were smoking sections was
it really in the 80s I think eighties
really that early 80s what coming little
marijuana is it smoky smoky or no smoky
smoky it's the nonsmoker wolf products
you could eat it like oils and a branch
lotion that's like non THC ones only CBD
ones or like I bet you this whole
schools gonna claim they got some kind
of stuff that they got a you know no TC
that's the worst CBD could get you
relaxed right I guess yeah tried all
that [ __ ] and getting a CBD cream this
week like eggs and stuff yeah for his
dick oh my wonderful numbs your dick it
probably does it's a cup it's a pain
reliever I'll try it
have you guys ever tried my viagra no no
what yeah you've ever asked that dude
because I always think about it no
because it's so fascinating the idea of
having like a [ __ ] 14-hour erection
but no but a lot of people if you don't
have erectile dysfunction and you take
it it [ __ ] up its it yeah if but I
mean a lot of people doctors just
one-timer
there's people that's done it one time
and then they had like a 48-hour
erection and then after that they could
never get a hard-on holy [ __ ] they mix
it with an alcohol and they mixed it
with like other stuff yes we were doing
all kind of weird [ __ ] but then if you
don't have it then either speeds up the
process to where you will get it or like
it just [ __ ] with you and that's for
anything like it they say like if I
rather drink Tiger dick alcohol or some
[ __ ] if you have an erection that lasts
longer than a day that you need to go to
the hospital immediately
really you could die the erectile
dysfunction so like you got to get that
fixed oh I see your soul dies your
manhood dies did for the
of your life yeah your dick gets
inverted and then it just becomes a slit
just becomes a question mark for some
that's how I go on the ocean
oh it just goes all the way up in you
guys kind of just shrivels up and goes
away yes
can you go swimming and then your penis
just goes I'm disappearing for a while
yeah so my job's you've done becomes a
sea sea animal yeah no one IP you know
that that straw trick when you put water
on you see the straw grow it slowly like
unravels itself yeah for like 30 seconds
before the first dream comes out so
accurate I imagine you know when you
take off latex gloves yeah and then if
you're gonna put those same clubs
getting up the flowing it's it's not
that fast
no it looks like a sea creature
especially when it's cold yeah it's gone
bob testicles man they just up and gone
man like nowhere to be seen
that empty sack it just shrinks up
because it's so cold it goes right into
your body what they do for our bodies is
crazy yeah he likes temperature that's
insane
what where are testicles do for our
bodies though the real MVP dude I feel
like that's like another little person
dude like yeah it is like you should
count movie you need to pay for an extra
ticket if you go to you don't I mean
because they have like personality oh
yeah it's like if you get a stick and
you poke a sea urchin and it closes up
slowly like that that's what the
testicle does - yeah it's got the same
amount of intelligence it gets hot it's
like Oh get away from my body
it's like that bit nummies jungle fern
what are you tap it it just goes yes
close slowly so in Florida the school
board unanimously voted to approve
medical marijuana on school grounds so
but they will only be administered by
the people like their own parent or
their own Guardian their own caregiver
so they're making a business out of this
no oh the only parent or guardian
administrator oh I thought they were the
only ones that were gonna be able to
like how old there's one girl she's
entering the sixth grade she suffers
from epilepsy
well she need this [ __ ] her mom
administers it to her and she says that
she actually has an identification card
that says
that she the only person who can
administer medication I just thought it
was a bunch of kids with joints
everywhere there wasn't so funny yeah
like this little girl who has seizures
like the fact that you got to join her
mouth the whole day she's like oh man
what do you wanna know what's that [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] they just
constantly shake they have tremors
consistently Parkinson's yeah
Parkinson's right and they there was
that video the guy who took the CBD oil
or yeah he just goes like he's like this
the whole time and he goes anybody
hungry
did you eat lunch yet that's insane yeah
and like I guess like whatever state
that was in they banned it bro like what
the [ __ ]
so they're kind of complain like are you
[ __ ] kidding me this guy needs it
like legit his tremors are like this I'm
not even exaggerating
dude the dad that had the baby we didn't
hear that I had the baby that had that
suffer from epilepsy once they were he
was administering uh what is it CBD to
it like the baby was chill and then he
got in trouble and I think got fine
weed it's like the miracle drug home
dude so he's going like this from this
till I see it in the video in real time
and then he's [ __ ] playing Jenga
[Laughter]
he's a drawing perfect circles on the
chalkboard [ __ ] he's like shaking like
this he can't and then they have them
lay on the couch for a second and then
two minutes later he goes can you talk
he gets up he goes wow did you did you
have lunch yet or that's the ultimate
Jenga shark if you really think about it
yeah do you want to play Jenga 6000
bucks if you beat me [ __ ] yeah play you
know alright let's go [ __ ]
ice cold precision
it's wild it was like it was like a drop
of sea BP oil or something like that -
Wow can't make that [ __ ] illegal as a
miracle drug I once played a human-sized
gene that was scary that sounds fun how
big is the plot I was in Singapore and
they had it was like as big as this
bookshelf it was [ __ ] huge right I'd
be scared of like you're scared what
it's teetering it's like because when it
falls it like comes down so the winner
of survives wait how do you go cuz you
have to play settle on the top yeah so
you have to you have to very carefully
and then you have to try to like jump
and there's no ladder some people put
use chairs and I was like that's [ __ ]
lame beside the tall guy yeah well
exactly
sounds fun hell it was fun a spot though
that's gory so in Florida under federal
law Florida has a lot other drug
problems to worry about that I want you
guys [ __ ] all of a sudden it's
illegal everywhere in federal law
federal law is illegal but states are
doing their own thing which is weird how
we have these conflicting laws it's
really weird yeah makes sense as far as
federal versus state but the law itself
doesn't make sense to me I just don't
like the smell of weed so that's the
only gripe I have about it really dunk
it is pretty skunky just for me in
general I just don't like not feeling in
control you know so you like to drink by
I'm still a controller like I don't I
don't get smashed
you know you drink the buzz you get a
little whoa yeah you know we enjoy
ourselves
we've makes you go out of control no we
I get the spins I get all this [ __ ] oh
you might be allergic or if you just get
like a small hit then it's just a head
changer and you feel a light I don't but
it doesn't [ __ ] with your head I don't
like that light feeling I don't like
that slight delay I like the door I hate
it so when I was high I [ __ ] hated it
oh that's irritating yeah some people do
get paranoid too and they get irritated
from it it was like I was paranoid it
was just like a thought would come and
there was a delay and I hate that oh
aren't that though they when you drink
there's no delay no it's beautiful that
makes you feel like your sharpest [ __ ]
even though you're not
you sound like this what have I ever who
sounded like that when I was drunk the
part of weed that I like is like every
single simple part of your life becomes
an epiphany so you like unscrew this and
you're like this [ __ ] unscrews like that
yeah dude this is the size of a roll of
pennies it's just everything is just
like [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] genius and I
like I feel like I'm the water and I'm
like sliding down the bottle like I feel
I got way more senses but that's for
noobs right like just I've known so many
cool stoners we were just cool as [ __ ]
when they're hot like Snoop Dogg dude
you know Snoop Dogg okay use it make the
whole time
oh it's tight but I don't know him but
he was cool hey snoop its Steve green
and Logan Paul is my friend first of all
close friend I told you very UFC fight I
said hey Steve greens my friend - yeah
and he's like with who he was joking
with you it's a joke we do yeah we're
very close yo yo what he calls me area
did you just get stoned David I'm
talking about it oh yeah I guess like my
the one thing I just don't like even
with alcohol or any of that stuff too is
I don't like when people are dependent
on something to feel normal
yes you should be able to function with
them without that ailment it doesn't
matter you know and I think like I know
so many people who need to have that to
be normal I know what that felt like
yeah being sober was so weird to me like
I was like I hate feeling sober I I need
weed or something like they always need
to feel medicated to feel normal and
that's a thing that I have I don't like
that
now I'm the opposite now I'm like I have
to prep my mind like I'm a smoke then I
better not have any priorities the next
day because I'm just brain dead oh
really
I used to be able to smoke every [ __ ]
day I can't do that anymore like I got a
kind of plan it out like alright I'm on
vacation do I have to be like really
think II do I have to think about [ __ ]
well awesome spunk biggest all right
that was fun
yeah let me warm vacation you know and
it's a legal there now not federally the
strain that I had my mind was clear
throughout the whole process but it was
still like I was
so that's the craziest thing when I'm
super aware I didn't I usually go out of
town like in my head I'm just like damn
water bottles yeah you know in my head
I'm out of town the RV we're gonna do
that [ __ ] were you focusing on some [ __ ]
you lose track of time it's been like
five minutes but it feels like it's been
three hours yeah that's my epiphanies
that I have now me I'm just like why my
[ __ ] stone that's so stupid while I'm
doing this why did I do this [ __ ] I
don't even like this [ __ ] that was me
[Music]
Oh